this video was supported in part by our
friends at Monday comm find out how
Monday comm can boost your team after
this video
[Music]
our world is sleep-deprived hairy yes
everything in the last century people
slept an average of 9 hours per night
today more than half the world's
population gets by on less than 7 hours
of sleep per night but in an age of
non-stop stimuli what do you expect to
sleep is to miss out on something so why
sleep at all what if we didn't need
sleep could we do it without being
cranky could we stay awake and survive
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you no longer needed sleep
sleep is simply one of those things you
just can't live without at least not yet
your heart your lungs your brain and
your metabolism all need a good night's
rest to work their best without enough
sleep you increase your risk of high
blood pressure depression diabetes
obesity and cardiovascular disease not
to mention any infections that might
prey on your weakened immune system put
that coffee down but in 1965 a 16 year
old stayed awake for 11 days straight
without sustaining any permanent side
effects and in 2007 researchers tested a
new drug on primates that reduce the
negative effects of sleep deprivation
and boosted their cognitive performance
so the big question is could we one day
live without sleep the average person
spends about a third of their life
asleep in a world where we'd no longer
need sleep you'd have an extra eight
hours to play with
would you use it to see more family and
friends would you learn a new skill pick
up a new hobby or unleash your creative
potential of course not everyone would
see this as free time the longer you're
awake the more money you'll spend and
the more money you dun doubtedly have to
earn your grocery bill for instance
could easily double if the average
person eats three meals within twelve
hours you'd probably have to eat twice
as much to have enough energy to last
you for 24 hours along with your food
consumption your fuel consumption would
also go up and with it your
environmental impact it wouldn't just be
from people driving more often but also
from people having their lights on more
often because everyone would be awake
all the time
the workaholics among us would surely
increase their time at the office along
with anyone else looking to make an
extra buck and of course with more
people working overtime stress levels
would increase and not sleeping would
certainly make the problem worse
so 24 hour therapists would be in high
demand along with 24 hour restaurants
and 24 hour farmers yeah we would need
so much more food and not just because
everyone's eating more but because those
of us who aren't working longer hours
might still feel inclined to be more
productive so population would increase
and there would be more people to look
after we need to train armies of first
responders in order to serve protect and
save a growing restless public with more
hours in the day we might be able to
speed up our progress and find cures to
some of the world's most challenging
illnesses the curious minds of the world
would have more time to innovate and
Explorer delivering new technologies and
making fresh discoveries ahead of their
time
who knows we might even make it to Mars
sooner than expected
or would we just end up wasting more
time not if you're on Monday com Monday
comm is the easiest team management tool
you'll ever use look at it it's colorful
it's intuitive but the best part about
it is it boosts transparency and ramps
up collaboration among teams of any size
Monday comm automates your workflow and
keeps track of who's doing what you know
making these videos for you our team
here at what-if knows a lot about
deadlines we finished this video
yesterday and we'll have another new one
for you tomorrow you never have to fear
the deadline when your team is in sync
and empowered to do their best work on
time stress free there are plenty of
smart ways to be productive but cutting
back on sleep is definitely not one of
them
studies show that humans are
intellectually productive for roughly
six hours a day and that's provided we
allow ourselves some downtime to
recharge so it's not guaranteed that a
sleepless society would get more done we
might simply be faced with the problem
of having too much time on our hands and
if you don't think that's possible
just remember the last time you had to
kill a few hours of time let's just say
that movies TV and video games would
become a lot more popular along with
bars and definitely coffee shops so
whether you get your full 7 hours or
just 40 winks your buddy needs to take
breaks you can handle a late night once
in a while but if you go too long
without adequate sleep you'll eventually
break down so pick your poison
coffee Red Bull or a new pill on the
market you still can't replace sleep and
why would you anyway productivity is
great excitement is great but isn't
relaxing on a bed pretty great to get a
full night's sleep tonight and see how
refreshed you feel tomorrow do you think
maybe you'd sleep more if you could
control your own dreams well
that's a story for another what if
[Music]
you